we are finding the defendant like this
turns it around it just says guilt it's
a beautiful a beautiful painting of the
defendant in prison just like this
with one shaft of light for me
drunk
[Music]
we're rolling rolling rolling rolling
rolling rolling rolling an A.D
rolling rolling rolling that's what I
want to ask you about because we're just
talking about this started before the
air
before the error airing of this podcast
what I want to know is if you were gonna
get
a tattoo and you have some right
if you were gonna get a tattoo
um
and you could do it efficiently like say
you want to get a chess piece rather
than sitting there for 10 hours or 15 20
hours total whatever depending on the
the intricacy of the chest piece
if you could just go and just
and you're done with lasers would you
rather do that
is it all everything is the same
everything's exactly the same I mean the
obvious I know I know and it would not
no besides like people that read and
subscribe to Inked Mac right nobody
I okay I would too I would go in and go
I would do that right but
I would feel cheaper about it would you
well to find that like I would feel like
it's not as good even even take everyone
else I'm not even counting like you
didn't even you wouldn't even have to
tell anybody that you did the laser [__]
still is it cheaper though like is it
chintzier or like worse or no no well
well they don't do it yet I know there's
no flying cars okay so I'm just saying
in this hypothetical though is it
actually cheaper or Worse no everything
is the same and I would not know then I
would not no only if it was actually
worse or there was an argument to be
made that it was actually worth there's
not then no it's better in fact because
you save time exactly that's why I would
do it yeah I just feel like it's
ingrained in me that you have to sit
there and take it which is so stupid but
that's only because that's true what
that's the only way to get a tattoo yeah
that's true I feel like if it well okay
if all of a sudden you could laser
tattoos on on and it would be exactly
the same people would do it there would
be a huge community that was like oh you
ain't people who subscribe to Inked mag
right but that's true of literally every
single thing yes I know there's a
community they're like I know the new
ways I know that stupid I know I know I
know but
um that sucks that that's ingrained in
me even though I I don't even agree with
it yeah I have something I want to talk
to you about too okay get on my mind oh
do you are you done yeah I guess so do
you maybe would lead to something else
but do you think that
I'm not going to talk about this is not
like a political question it's going to
start out sounding like I know I talk
about in my in my in my show bleep that
out
um and it's not political and I can tell
sometimes people clap because they are
political about I'm like dude it's not
political right boobs I like the bleep
out that I said that word
all of you who do that okay so go ahead
um that's crazy we have to believe that
we do yeah so I'm so I've I'm actually
in the driver's seat right now so I'm in
the drive receiver go ahead so
um Joe Biden is as of now running and I
gotta believe that and that's all you
said yeah and I he's like struggling the
polls him and Trump are neck and neck
whatever who cares right repeat
um yeah exactly three Pete you know what
I mean uh no I don't but um
he would win I believe yeah he would win
in by a significant margin job if he did
one very simple thing okay you know the
song I can already tell this is not
political you know this song I'm so
excited yeah I'm so excited sure if he
this is already
so wrong no I believe it though nothing
with this so so excited thing so you
know how Trump had the YMCA thing like
he would do oh wow so corny but he would
do the guys offense right okay but it
became a whole thing stop talking about
bleeping things no a sensor the FCC
uh if Joe Biden came out to I'm so
excited but sang actually sang yeah I'm
Joey Biden
he might win my vote back right right
right right right because he does not
have my vote okay well relax because I
said we're not gonna apologize I know
that but uh but I just want to say and
yeah so if he did if he did that he
would win so I'm not a pundit
um
he would be like I'm wait who and he'd
have his aviators on and he would do
that and he would win so take my advice
don't take it it's up to you but if you
want to win
I know his AIDS I'll watch this show so
uh pass that along to him put it on the
thing but also um the White House huge
fan yeah the White House loves Lifeline
put on the thing on the TV
um
well that's weird he's not here he's
probably unloading right when we start
the show he was here the whole time
Anthony within the first 10 minutes
leaves his station he does doesn't he he
because he he goes about he goes to the
bathroom dude I don't even think he goes
to the bathroom to go to the bathroom I
think he goes to the bathroom and I
think he like order shirts orders more
shirts look at this phone utilities
so all right it's episode 77 what up my
babies uh go sign up for Lifeline luxury
it's actually on him popping over there
Lifeline luxury uh uh patreon.com
Lifeline luxury
um I'm gonna be in Cleveland oops I'm
going to be in Pittsburgh oops I'm going
to be in uh Virginia oops I'm gonna be
in Baltimore oops I'm gonna be in
Reading oops I'm gonna be in Sylvania
oops so go to chrisley.com and get
tickets for that man the show's been on
and popping baby on own and popular they
look like they've been crazy lately yeah
they've been pretty crazy man they've
been really great houses everybody's
clapping everybody's going crazy yeah
yeah it's like you're the Rolling Stones
well yeah you know but not really though
because I keep my shirt on and
um well I do kind of look like that guy
a little bit what's his name the lead
guy oh you don't know Mick Jagger's Mick
Jagger wow Mr Jagger I mean
um also uh you want advice is from Matt
go to mattelia.com he'll have a
one-on-one Sashi mcdeshi with him oh
well at delia.com yeah if you got a
question go down in the link below and
uh go to watch lifeline.com or go click
or you can also call in with the hotline
uh and the merch is awesome I think my
favorite thing is the purple hoodies the
purple hoodie is my favorite
lifelinemerch.com I can't wait for it to
get colder a little bit more so I can
start wearing it again but it is it is
the best piece of merch in the
thank you very much whoa Elvis
um yeah dude I uh
I I okay so well so insecure well let me
tell you something right now though okay
I'm not insecure okay that's don't we
wouldn't want to say that right I
wouldn't because I would go crazy okay
um but it was insecure but you look and
he was doing it wrong he left his
station and something was wrong great
great great great great
[Music]
so you uh have a really you put an
outfit together man did you mean to uh
did I do mean to match my colors yes I
do yeah but enough it makes me
uncomfortable when I here's the two
things I can do oh boy I can no no my
fiance I can streamline I know Chris
Marco my outfit
okay and with the color color wise right
right so a match generally speaking like
this is obviously yellow or neon yellow
and gray and I have this hat on and gray
shoes so it's like I can do that or I
mean that's not something that that's
very easy but or I can completely have
like a disarray go against the
traditional
color scheming and just have like nine
colors and just be basically you dress
like Patch Adams like I fell into my
closet a few things ended up on my body
and then I got out and didn't even look
wow but I cannot okay
have like
I generally match but there's one thing
off I can't do that
yeah it's slightly it's like a rock in
the shoe it bothers me I agree though oh
okay I agree I think uh
like I had on different shoes here I
have on this Ollie's Kingston New York
Pizza thing I went there I have this
shirt on and I was gonna wear these uh
orange shoes but it didn't really match
with this right
so I walked was that red what is it
right it's like kind of pinkish Orange
I'm just like I look at it I'm just like
a teacher and so it looked right I had
to put these on because they matched
better
because I had on a little bit of orange
shirts on uh orange shoes on it was like
this and it just looked weird oh that
would that would be all right for me I
think yeah yeah well you're not as
fashion forward as I am right I mean
that's can we all agree possibly true we
definitely have very different styles
thank god
um but yeah now you have actually not
bad calves what you don't have bad
calves okay why do I have bad calves I
don't even know what a bad calf would be
what what makes mine not bad they're not
that skinny oh really I mean I have
really skinny weird legs don't I well
little didn't you look at me and you go
oh he's on stilts oh you have weirder
legs than me I mean I never my knees go
backwards like a T-Rex like a chicken
dude mine do too they when I stand when
he's locked they go oh right I show you
they curve the wrong way yeah [__] boy
right nope
um all right well let's get into some
stuff dude
um but uh we have a great time go to
Lifeline luxury.com or no sorry uh
patreon.com Lifeline luxury to join
Lifeline luxury and uh get the episode
words on patreon that are only on
patreon exclusively on patreon and here
we go
what's up Matt what's up Chris love the
podcast Chris I saw you when you were in
Denver it was an awesome show anyways
today my question is regarding my
marriage and my friend in prison oh my
God so I have a good friend who's been
in prison for the last I think three
years and I'm getting married next
August now a couple years ago
I told him that he could be at our
wedding and we would wait to have the
wedding until he got out problem is
wedding stuff is so crazy that you have
to book it yeah so far out yeah that we
couldn't wait another year to do it and
honestly it's kind of trashy to hold a
wedding for one guy in person that's not
even family
you know what I mean
how do I tell him he calls every once in
a while and I still haven't brought it
up I don't know how to tell him any
advice would be great thank you so what
I don't understand yet is
it's so hard to book stuff so he has to
book stuff soon
did you understand what he was saying
yeah it's really annoying that you would
get hung up on that but I do understand
what you're saying okay so what does he
mean by that though that's annoying that
I would get hung up on that yeah because
it doesn't matter you know ultimately
yeah yes but if we're dealing with
somebody who's saying stuff that doesn't
matter
it sounds like they didn't know exactly
when he was going to get out they booked
a date and then to cancel it now they'd
have to book it even further they're
using deductive reasoning that may be
right but he should have been but that's
what we all do every day all day long we
don't do that we would never get
anywhere if we didn't deduce things
that's pretty much because people never
make sense so because people never make
sense we have to make sense for them
fill in the gaps that's what we're doing
all day long non-stop literally every
time someone speaks I try to be as
specific as I possibly I know that
that's why you're supremely annoying
oh what uh about the guy's advice
I know what you do
you call the guy or the guy calls you
from prison and say you say hey look man
I know I told you I was gonna wait for
you to get out uh a prison to so you
could be in my wedding but the problem
is I want to get married and you're
still in prison and that's a problem you
shouldn't have killed anyone you should
dude how about this how about this and
the guy in prison goes like this
you're lucky I'm in here yeah because if
I was out I'd kill you too yeah that
that is the movie that played out in my
head like you tell him and he's just
like okay and then he for the next year
he's like throwing darts at photos of
your face
like Max Katie yeah yeah I mean he's
your friend he'll understand because
he's in prison
the guy can't do anything and I think
one thing that people tend to deal with
probably first when they get sent to the
clink for a long time is they
it sinks in that they're gonna miss out
on life that happens outside also this
is your friend this is not your mother
yeah it's crazy you know it's crazy
honestly what do you hey but that you
even what are you doing that you even
feel bad at all is kind of sweet and
enough you know hey bud he shouldn't
have stole that car or whatever you know
I really wonder what he did
I always I'm like he's still a car you
know what I don't know I fill it in and
I go they stole a car it's possible I've
said this before on this podcast but
there's no way I could ever I could ever
be on a jury and the reason is I would I
would never
say guilty you have said this I know I
would never I just I wouldn't want that
on my own conscious I don't care I have
no sense of like Vengeance on behalf of
other people if someone kills someone in
my family obviously I wouldn't be in the
jury because I'm biased but I would want
to kill them right but like
out in the world it's all immaterial to
me someone I don't want them to go to
jail I don't want them to go I get it I
feel like that a lot a lot I mean I
don't care if they go to jail because
they did something wrong I don't want it
no I know you're saying yeah I know what
you're saying
um yeah dude get married man be happy
and then when he gets out or here's
another thing you can do is have the
wedding at the prison yeah imagine the
the the the the
wife's dad the Father of the Bride like
not what I expected but at least he
doesn't have to pay much for it although
many prisons are a lot to rent out I
don't you need a lot uh security be like
okay so we got a block of rooms uh it's
pretty much cell block d uh but you
wanna get them quick there's a hotel in
the neighborhood but it's not as nice
I mean like what goes on in the the guy
that called the guy that's made yeah
what goes on this guy's head so yeah the
knife is like the night before is like
oh man it was great uh so yeah
everyone's pretty much cool uh your aunt
got your aunt got ripped but um wow we
gotta believe that
your aunt got shanked yeah you're yeah
your aunt got shanked uh she's fine she
still wants to come uh can we hurried up
though
yeah this isn't kind of a non-problem
yeah but I I get it you're probably a
little too sensitive though you got to
let this go you gotta let it go you can
ask for advice for a reason because we
know what's up we cut through the
[__] hey get the wedding done bro
yeah also congratulations yes
next all right
Dead Hand [__] hey Matt and Chris uh
Matt I've noticed you and I like a lot
of the same stuff on Instagram anytime
there's a super weird person doing
something really strange on Instagram
reels I can save back
which makes me laugh
um my question today though is a bit of
a random one so I was recently overseas
in Europe in a country that the Delia
family has a bit of Heritage in let's
just say that I don't want to dox anyone
um but I was at this beach club and I
was taking some photos and footage I'm a
Travel Photographer so that's what I do
every day I go there I create content
and oftentimes I'll post it online it'll
blow up for these places that uh and
they get a lot of exposure on this
particular occasion though uh when I was
taking footage and and doing all that
kind of thing that I do every day uh the
club took exception to it and three of
the employees from this club came
zooming up on motorbikes proceeded to
bash me up take all my camera gear
ripped my shirt uh and held me hostage
for about three hours two other guys
came they were all speaking in their
local language
uh laughing at me belittling me
emasculating me for quite a while until
the cops came eventually and let me go
which ended up being just such a
non-event it was such a weird situation
and something that really like
traumatized me for that day fortunately
everything ended up okay and it ended up
not being too much of a big deal but uh
I felt very powerless yeah um now I'm
back home uh I feel like I have a bit of
power back and I want to get them back I
want to I want them to suffer I don't
want to just write a shitty review for
them because they've got plenty of those
even though it's a really nice place but
I really want to get the owner back this
guy was really mean really rude he had a
rotten soul and I want to [__] him over
a little yeah
um so what can I do to get them back
that isn't too spiteful but will
potentially let them know that what they
did was not okay without jeopardizing my
safety in the future when I go back to
that country if you have any ideas
please let me know because what these
guys did to me was really traumatic at
the time wow and I think they deserve
some kind of recommendation I feel like
you guys will have some good ideas dude
the story made sense hope you guys have
got good ideas and keep doing what
you're doing crazy
dude that's terrible dude that's crazy
and we got connections
we got connections yeah hey hey dude
you don't want to [__] be from our
heritage where our town is and where
we're from dude
we're connected dude and we'll get you
we'll [__] you send us a private link
of of what this [__] place is and
I'll tell you this much dude hey you
ever heard us uh
swim Stephen with the fishes drunk dude
that's crazy that's terrible
um that's upsetting man what is wrong
with people what what here's what you do
dude
you're a good he's a good looking guy he
is yeah
uh
find his wife and oh and be even if you
just flirt with her yeah even if that's
where it ends yeah the guy you're in the
guy's head even even if it's just that
here's what you do
if you end up smashing
well a mime a mine
if you're in a smashing bro
yeah huh
you have to say words now
do I you're Mr Phil's in the gaps I'm
just saying it's like bro this is not
cool that's not cool I don't know what
they did to them they at least belittled
him is what we heard no he's they
physically roughed him up yeah that's
insane
what is dude what is this like what
dude kill him pick him up one by one
kill every single one of them
yeah
yeah no he's just like or I caught him
so what you want to do is
find out who his wife is you're a good
looking guy you're obviously better
looking than the guy that owns that
place of course well yeah honestly
nobody good looking is ever that angry
enough to be like that kind of person
that's true right huh it's just one of
the unfortunate facts of life is just a
ground level truth people that are good
looking are never so mad they want to
rough you up for taking a picture of
them that's why I've never done that
I almost got I almost got roughed up
once I took a picture of a motel in uh I
mean what's up with taking pictures of
places that Nevada and these two
Tweakers came out were like were you
taking pictures of I was like the sign
of your Motel you're like what's what's
the problem I was like nothing I like
the sign of your Motel no like get out
of here man where are you from I have
the California place you know California
like there's no problem here anywhere at
all on any level I mean maybe it was
like a drug then I have no idea probably
but uh anyway so well stories don't take
pictures of places find the guy's wife
behind his back
develop a relationship with her online
do the Long play yeah yeah yeah and like
dm with her and talk to her and flirt
with her get compromising pictures of
her okay well this is okay not
compromising not to like mess with her
oh but then just get enough of them huh
and send the pictures
send the pictures to him yeah and then
in addition to sending the pictures of
him send pictures that you took of his
Resort at another time that you got away
with
so who knows but like don't actually
don't send it from your account just
send him pictures that you took and
pictures of his wife I would love it if
he took selfie went back secretly took
selfies of him at the resort that's just
good yeah and just kept tagging him yeah
yeah yeah that would be good too there's
a number of things you can do dude uh it
sounds like he'd been there more than
once if you've taken pictures I know
they took your camera and [__] it all
up which is insanity what what is what
are they protecting exactly if it's a
little beautiful place exactly this guy
takes beautiful pictures
taking pictures of drug dens yeah no
it's it sounds like there was no problem
to begin with and these guys were just
being but that's what's weird though is
it that's weird though because if you're
in America if that happens in America
you have you have actionable stuff you
can do after that right and you probably
do in Italy as well you just don't know
where it was
right but
um it's a secret you know yeah yeah but
we don't know okay we don't know it
could be anywhere but um but you don't
really feel you do you're a foreigner
you don't really feel like you know
uh that this is something that you can
kind of see through and also you don't
know the laws there but also I mean
traumatized you just want to get out of
there like everybody press charges and
stay there yeah just get out of there I
know right yeah I totally I totally get
why he would yeah of course no I know
I'm saying no that's that's a nightmare
man God people like that drive me
absolutely they do too yeah especially
foreigners that do it right I would say
because I bleed red I'm American I would
send them to jail I would send those
three guys to jail how
like if I was on a jury oh got it
calling it back if you're on the
gerissimo yeah yeah
a telephone Jody yeah hello we
are Simo they come in it's like it's
like beautiful like just like straight
up bitch-faced women and like just like
fat cannoli and like dudes you know
right being racist yeah yeah and then
just like somebody realizes it that you
can be so racist towards Italians
painting someone painting come in with
painting like beautiful like still life
like a [__] some oranges and [__]
with a hat and it just goes like this a
guilty
we are finding the defendant like this
turns it around it just says guilt it's
a beautiful a beautiful painting of the
defendant in prison just like this
was one shaft of light
[Laughter]
dude he just
not like this like this
dude he's so exciting to have a finger
he's doing a courtesy flash I guess
wow because the other guys in the in the
sitting on the bunk bed like this
yeah I call it as a courtesy flash
we find the defendant
wow
well nobody's ever done that in the
history of man what I've done what I did
right there yeah what I said and the
thing the two things I did nobody's ever
done that in the whole history of man
it's funny I think about that sometimes
too okay but I I did that I'm unique
have you ever done something like that
yeah do you think yeah yeah no I have I
know I have okay well dude if you were
to be do something like that's been done
dude I totally agree okay so I'm just
saying to be truly unique yeah yeah yeah
yeah okay no I know so I did that I'm
with you we find that the defendant
didn't
nobody's ever
nobody's ever done what I just did yeah
I agree okay I mean I I can't agree
because I don't know but like I I also
believe what to be true what you said
okay
and I know this to be true
next one
oh is that Spiderman my wife and I grew
up very strict Baptist we went to church
three times a week we never drank we
never listened to normal music just
church music people like this um
recently we switched to a different
church this church in my eyes just makes
a lot more sense it's more chill they
have what they call contemporary
Christian music uh they think drinking's
okay here's the thing this is the one
church that my wife's parents always
said if anywhere don't go there there we
go it's basically the ultimate
disappointment to these very strict
people and so my wife and that's why
he's driving this she feels like she has
to inform them that we're going there
and that it's going to be a huge
disappointment how do we go about this
I don't think we necessarily need to
tell them what do you think thanks
I mean you don't need to tell them
except for it might get back to them and
in which it could it does does that
matter enough to your wife that you you
know because she could always be like
well why did we need to tell you
I get the whole thing is absolutely so
stupid it's just so bad at the beginning
what are these people seven years old
like get over it people are different
they do different things what's crazy is
that the parents are probably upset the
reason they're upset is because they're
worried that their daughter's gonna go
to hell now that is dumb yeah she's not
gonna go to Hell she's [__] married
to Spiderman yeah I mean come on no but
uh
I
I think
if she wants to tell them you have to
because she's the daughter of the the
yeah you're the son-in-law yeah so you
got to kind of go with what she wants to
do so tell them and when they start tell
them about like a family dinner yeah at
home not like out to dinner and then you
say
or they you know she says so you know
that I would go into this church now I
know you know and approve that but I
just want to let you know so you don't
find out some other way and then when
the parents start to express
you know that they're angry or that
they're upset
that's when you come in and you say that
that doesn't matter past the potatoes
wow oh wow that's when you come in
so stupid it doesn't matter guys
uh I mean that is such a crazy thing
that so many people struggle with this
kind of thing I know during my advice
sessions I've talked to a lot of people
who are are or have been raised
religious oh wow and they're in their
20s now and they live close enough to
their parents and they're like I don't
know how to separate from the church
because my parents are going to be so
upset they're going to think I'm going
to go to hell I'm wow that is such an I
mean life is hard for everybody and it's
all relative but that is such an
interesting and strange to me foreign to
me yeah problem to have and I really
empathize because that sounds like
miserable yeah it's miserable but nobody
wants to go to h e Dola hockey sticks
you know nobody wants to go to H2 double
hockey nobody wants to go to AG double
holoca hockey sticks but no one is I
know did you know did you know that I
know I know that but it's good nobody
wants to go to nobody wants to go to
two lines and a line connecting them
backwards three double hockey sticks
nobody wants to go there wow nobody
wants to go there wow but I um
nobody wants to go to uh you no but
nobody is still of an upside down you to
a backwards three double nobody wants
that so complicated but
um yeah no nobody is going to ahu double
hockey sticks but uh do you know why
because it's not a place I I know that I
know that okay I know that I know it's
not a place okay but neither is Fry's
Electronics anymore but size is not I
don't price isn't around I don't think
so that he knows they went out of
business I wonder what they did with
that alien spaceship that crash landed I
have it I bought it someone's 20 grand
I'm jealous it was 20 grand but it's in
a scrap yard it's bad it was a bad
investment it's still there I think the
fries has no idea just set it you know
absolutely [__] said it it's still
there I think just set it you know what
I mean people just it was there a few
months ago the cojones fries or the
alien spaceship the abandoned fries with
the [__] alien thing in the uh on the
facade okay
there's one inside though too and that's
the one I like oh
you know what I'm talking about
oh
um
yeah dude just just go tell the parents
and let them be mad you know you're not
in control of their of how they're
reacting you're not in control of you
right but you're just in control of what
you do and they're not in control of you
though you're right and they're not in
control of you so they got to deal with
it
they're not they should if they get
super mad say you know what just be
happy we're still going to church relax
okay yeah it's so a church
nothing's wrong with it we're all
Christian we're all we're all the same
religion
we all still believe in the same things
so relax
now let's sing Kumbaya it's not no but
it's not like they did they leave
they're leaving the religion it's just a
different Church bro how bad is this you
don't need to get over it dude yeah I
mean Kumbaya My Lord Kumbaya
[Music]
is it even really a song someone's
swimming what is it I don't know
someone's singing it's definitely not
swimming someone's in the pool
oh my God
I hope they're not drowning my Lord grab
a stick that one's not long enough my
Lord
oh my God the [__] stick broke my
Lord wow now he's headed down the
goddamn River I have a pain in my neck
my Lord isn't because I said God damn
I mean then it would be good that song
rips that song rips dude all right let's
go next one
my name is Austin I live in Nashville
Tennessee Chris I just saw you at the
Ryman theater you [__] killed it bro
thanks so much
[__] yeah dude they're aggressive anyway
Chris on your congratulations podcast
the last uh episode you just did you
mentioned how you went to Soho House
Nashville while you were here uh and you
were really [__] confused if it was a
restaurant or it was a hotel right uh
you're in the right man it makes no
[__] sense if I worked there put in
my two weeks on the way out oh wow uh my
question is I'm a photographer and I get
a lot of face time with a lot of A-list
uh celebrities
uh musicians specifically and I've been
just blatantly asking them like yo can I
shoot your show tonight yeah and 80 of
the time they're like totally down for
it the other 20 they're like I gotta
talk to my manager or some [__] right
um what do you guys think about this is
this too much like am I a dick for doing
that because people have been making me
feel like I'm stupid or like I need to
be uh kind of watching out because I
might get blacklisted or some [__] it
which is [__] stupid I don't know
because they're just putting celebrities
on like a pedestal and being like oh
they're unapproachable they're not
they're normal ass people yeah is it
okay to be doing this it's worked uh let
me know your thoughts how you would feel
as people in the public eye if this
happened to you anyway October 21st Jack
White theater go see crystalia uh get
your crystalia tickets at crystalia.com
maybe let's get it is that Detroit what
is that Cleveland I'll be there scared I
mean it's okay I'll say hi to him dude I
I I get this I get this people say can I
shoot your show tonight and if they're
good I say yes if they're not good I
either don't respond to them or I send
them to Sam my videographer guys say If
you think this guy's good have him come
if you don't don't or I say no
it's okay to say no I think it now look
of course it is but this is not his
question go on but I know this guy seems
to be pretty
normal and you know despite the glasses
and the aggression yeah but that was
just for fun but like he seems pretty
normal like if if
if he asked me to shoot my stuff and I
had seen his stuff and I didn't like it
I would just say
I already got a guy and you know I don't
I don't know I don't think I don't think
so but you know I I and and I think he
would probably be like okay well he said
some of them say no so obviously well no
he what he said was someone said I gotta
talk to my manager and [__] like that
but which is fine too but like you know
I I feel like people need to
no
it's all about I hate this word but it's
all about boundaries like if you're if
somebody asks you something and the
answer is no and you get butt hurt about
it that's all on you it's not on the
person who said no I mean and he seems
like he's able to take it yeah yeah but
he seems like he's able to take that
yeah you know yeah so wait hold on I'm
being you for a second but he's asking
if it's okay for him to ask yes that's
what he's asking the answer is yes yeah
100 yes you can ask yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah it's okay yeah now there are
annoying ways to do that totally right
so don't do that yeah right like I get
approached in Annoying [__] ways and
then I get approached in cool ways so in
his sense I'm imagining it goes like
this they're doing the photo shoot and
then at the end of the shoot hey I know
you're in town for a gig can I come
shoot it that's the wrong way and my
whole thing is if you're already doing a
photo shoot with the people you're
obviously you're gonna say yes I
wouldn't understand why somebody would
say no unless they just didn't like your
stuff but in which case why are they
shooting with you in the first place
right yeah
um but also um I would say no
well just for
because then I would think well maybe he
wants to hang out with me later and I
don't want to do that yeah but you you
have guys to be like just give them a
pass I don't you know oh right he shoots
in the thing and it's all good but they
if they're good they know they're not
[__] right right of course yeah yeah
you know
um but I have got like we had a guy who
came with us Matt what's this I'm gonna
let me look him up because what if it
was me and he had to look me on that
Delia there it is
um he was great but um Let me let me put
him out here
um he traveled with us through the whole
um Canadian stuff he's the guy went to
E40
Hugo he would take a shot he goes here
we go
um
and uh I wish so
he's just the craziest route
I'm on stage I hear in the crowd of here
oh that's a great one Porter um so uh no
but I I um yeah I I don't like I have
there's another guy too undeniable media
on Instagram who's great and he has to
shoot my show in I think it was Kansas
somewhere I don't know but he travels to
La he shot golden hour the other day
like he's a great photographer if you
know I think that's how you get your
name out there I don't understand the
blacklisted thing uh maybe that's the
thing what does he mean by that I think
what he means is you get the rep of you
ask people to to take pictures and it's
unprofessional maybe you ask I don't
know I yeah I don't I don't know maybe
and then maybe like bands will be like
yo that guy's gonna try to shoot you
don't do that
[Music]
I mean a monster but uh
okay hurt my throat well good I mean
honestly hurt my throat real bad
um so no you're good dude you did it you
do yeah I think it's okay you're just an
enterprising fellow it's okay I was uh
people got to be okay with this though
like the other day I was in Montreal and
three dudes came up to me
uh two of them said wait a minute no way
you're a [__] Legend bro like they're
like you're so funny no way and they're
like I was like oh [__] Chris you're the
man
the third guy goes like this who's this
guy yeah fine fine that's annoying yeah
a little annoying because don't do that
in front of my face just on principle
yeah I get not every most people don't
know who I am yeah the annoying part not
knowing who you are the annoying part is
in front of your face being like who's
this guy yes yes people do that like
it's a badge of honor too right right
they're like I don't have a TV like that
kind of [__] right nothing more annoying
I know so but I don't really care
they're like 20 something and they're
probably a little tipsy and like it's
night time and it happens and whatever
and
um
so then
they go like this guy's a comedian he's
[__] hilarious his podcast and [__]
like that the guy the third guy says oh
can I get a picture yeah and I said bro
you don't even know the [__] I am yeah
right yeah and the other two guys are
like oh dude and whatever and I'm like
yeah of course we get a picture I get a
picture with the three of them
we're looking across the street they're
talking they're like what are you doing
here in Montreal and I'm like I got a
show and this and that I'm with my crew
right and uh the light goes from green
to Red so now we're stuck we don't get
to cross the street right and they're
still talking and they're like oh man
and they're like do you know Bobby Lee
and I'm like yeah he's [__] hilarious
and [__] and they're like oh cool hey
are you gonna be on Rogan or whatever
the [__] saying all this [__] and
finally I go like this hey guys
we're done we're done here like that
right I said just like that and
they just go oh and I'm like
they didn't like laugh Oh weird which my
my people did so who cares but if you
know you they're fans I know yeah but I
was like yo guys I'm [__] with you
like yeah like it wasn't like they were
like [__] this but they were like oh oh
you know like yeah worried and I was
like guys [__] I'm joking yeah but
like what the [__] are we doing here you
know okay go hang out and they're like
no come to a bar with us and I'm like no
way right yeah you know and that's
that's okay to do yeah and if they were
butthurt about that which they're not
they're fine but that's on them so my
whole point is you've got to express
your boundaries and you have to
understand what you do if a guy's gonna
say no they're gonna say no then [__] it
and that's on them so don't suppose
their [__] on you basically you know
when they say no just be like oh who
cares why they said no they did but it
means nothing about whether it's okay to
ask him or not when they say no you go
this fine I don't want to shoot you
anyway
yeah dude can I see your show no I
didn't want to do it anyway fine
I'm gonna go ask Hoobastank
the reason is you
the reason is you Anthony's favorite
song when that song came out yeah dude
Anthony goes Anthony heard it first and
goes like this huh the second time you
heard it he legit was like like eyes got
watery and he was just like his
heartbeat wow this [__] is so good
dude his heart rate's sped out yeah I
did have that album dude of course he
did his other two favorite bands Lincoln
Park and Evanescence
big Evanescence song oh dude I can't
sing it because I'm so bad what is it
Marco what was it what is it Anthony
knows it wake me up inside right yeah
wake me up he has that tattoo he has a
tattoo of the lyrics on his side you
know yeah definitely How does it go
though again oh yeah the one that goes
wake me up
it's not them wake me up what is it
Anthony can sing it I'm not saying oh
you know what it is it goes like this
when I wake up and I know I'm gonna be
I'm gonna be the man who wakes up next
to you that's the proclaimer unless I
said we walk 500 000 miles that's
Proclaimers so what is it then uh I it's
on the tip of my tongue man I
it's okay
[Music]
oh yeah yeah yeah yeah
who's the guy in the back yeah oh yeah
yeah I think in that song it is Linkin
Park isn't it oh yeah they wake me up
inside
[__] yeah oh yeah the guy in the
background just absolutely having sex
having an orgy oh [__] you I'm so lucky
Wake me up inside all these chicks Wake
Me Up Inside
so dumb all right who's next baby
what is that in NBA 2k just got back
from Little Rock
a [__] guy in NBA 2k dude with such
good agility
oh his agility's off the charts look
it's all the way out at 10. I'm gonna be
honest I love this guy's head Chris just
got back from Little Rock seeing Chris
great show hell yeah great weekend
you're spotting my DM after the show so
this guy's going I appreciate that oh
yeah uh not much of an advice today just
wanted to see what you guys thought
about having like a routine when you
shower
um I do the standard shampoo conditioner
first but for some reason I always have
to go pits than junk and then chest and
then on from there I don't know why and
um also I can't be the only one that
gets done showering and uses my hand
like a squeegee to get the extra water
off I'm six five tall glass of water
got a lot of body to dry off and uh my
towels soaked at the end of it so can't
be having that so uh what you guys think
about shower routines and the worst is
it so [__] to wipe all the water off
yourself I like how mundane the
submission is
I mean we got to do all of them
no
mixing it up because he was playing NBA
2K dude damn it Anthony don't say wrong
[__] man he was playing NBA 2K listening
to Evanescence he got confused and
[__] got confused yeah
okay so do you have a routine don't say
junk that's first yeah don't ever say
when you're talking about your pricking
nuts don't say junk okay freaking nuts
like a a goddamn uh Cafe that would be
in Williamsburg you know [__] in New
York and everyone would be like dude you
gotta go pregnant
Around the Clock yeah or it will be in
[__] Los Feliz and be like you gotta
try this [__] place freaking nuts
everybody's like so pissed off you know
oh yeah what do you get there oh you got
to get the Mortadella sandwich dude one
nuts baby so that's what we call drunk
now
get the Mortadella sandwich with uh an
olive
um pistachio spread
it's dude it's so good at prick and nuts
in Williamsburg
all right so shower routine I
a while ago I realized I have one
without knowing I do like and I would
imagine that's true for almost
no dude he set it up
yeah it's like everybody does the same
[__] when they get in the shower
probably otherwise they that's just how
brains are they're just like they do
that you know I mean the guy from Place
Academy
foreign
damn you assassinated me with that dude
wow
it's a violent he assassinated with you
wow you stabbed me in the throat and
then pulled my tongue out of it and made
it tight around my neck and gave me a
Colombian necktie
ah
I love you what about you answer him and
then what was it the NBA 2K yeah I think
that you know whoever you want to play
on that game is fine what was the
question do you rather [__] routine
oh yeah I go in
um wash my junk no I go in
I wash
I guess I do I wash well I don't wash my
hair every day I have something
important to say about this actually yes
okay so
you're it's not
and I people are going to be like yeah
news I promise you okay it's I'm this is
not my idea I know this for a fact okay
I've read it numerous places I looked
into it it's just true okay it's not
good to wash your entire body every
single day it's not good for your body
French things
no just shower every day sure I'm just
saying don't use soap friends scrub
every single part of your body french
parts of your body need the things that
are happening on it to happen
like microbes and [__] you know what I
mean like I lost it right there
dips and [__]
from Brooklyn yeah
you need the microbes come on man eat up
um
because they don't know what they're
talking about you gotta eat this you
need a mini micro the things you have to
wash are jeans
the under here
the down in there an acting coach
they're behind the there all right and
the there the key area okay yeah you
don't like need to wash your like
forearms yeah
all right all right all right all right
all right so
okay
I
wash my hair maybe once every three days
I wash my body every day
I wash my armpits good I wash my
penile good wow I wash my crevice in the
backside very well you have to wash all
those things my feet
necessarily lather up right good good
good good good good good french but okay
um and that's that this obsession with
cleaning is wrong dude that was I hate
when people say stuff like this but it's
it was
it's like it was made up and sold to us
yeah just like women yeah armpits that
was made up by razor companies thanks
Hallmark now we got now we don't have
enough microbes so many things like that
that we all consider like gross if we
don't do them yeah it was literally made
up by some company or Corporation or
commemorative companies thank you
Hallmark and they just now 70 years
later we're all like if you don't do
that you're disgusting oh yeah you're
sheep
Alex Jones dude yo dude hey thank thanks
Hallmark dude hey thanks uh uh uh um for
sucking on the crank uh the teeth of uh
the crank of Hallmark hey dude thanks
dude I'd like to keep my microbes next
yeah hey uh hey Gillette yeah stop it
stop turning the frogs gay with the
water yeah whatever that means
he thinks the frogs are gay because of
the water God Alex and uh frankly I do
too
I I think all frogs are gay though you
know frogs are never wearing clothes
frogs are gay and they're always hanging
around each other and they're green
Anything Green is gay oh really yeah not
my money
stupid because it goes right into my
bank account
all right
next one
what's up guys Stefan here you're a long
time fan from Serbia hell yeah dude I
mean I called you know a few months ago
I mean the lighting is so Serbian I have
uh Jordan with the slab moment let's
find out it was a long time ago when I
was in elementary school I think seventh
grade something like that we went uh
outside of our city with the bus to have
a field trip and there was one girl in
my class that wasn't really in my group
let's say she was a bit odd I would say
okay and there was one moment when we
got a little bit bored me her all all
the kids I think and she said one thing
that I will never forget and to this day
I repeated that with my friends she said
um I will translate it to English but it
doesn't sound uh
because in Serbia we have this same oh
wow that I didn't know about it before
that because because I was a kid she
said I'm bored like a wafer on a grave
and you know in Serbian
it's kind of tradition when you go to
funeral to bring food because if you are
let's say your father mother died or
somebody like that close to you you
bring it you will have a lot of people
that know them there and you need to
offer to those people something so
some people do bring sweets like Wafers
and nobody's really eating that it's
just like I would say stupid tradition
and those Wafers stay there for days I
think and they get bored so wow that's
why she said I'm bored like away from a
grave and I never forgot it and it was
so funny I was crying laughing back then
and I repeat that
I mean almost every time I get bored
with my friends that know that joke so
yeah that's my story guys thanks man the
lighting was so Serbian so I mean the
lighting is like an art film yeah it's
Serbian dude yeah yeah I mean it's so
Serbian that's the lighting in his house
Always by the way uh so it is a saying
though
that's the only that's the thing that
butts up against the Jordan so here's
the thing
it is a Jordan with a slim if that is
not a saying but it is a saying so it's
not technical you so but he didn't know
it was a saying that that doesn't really
not make a difference but it does to him
in the moment all right but ultimately
to make it a Jordan with the slang can't
give it a Jordan talk about the slam but
it's definitely the closest it's the
closest any submission has been to a to
a true
Jordan with a slam saying it wrong but
yeah Jordan with us okay well that one
hurt me that is the closest we've ever
gotten yeah it's debatably not it's not
technical it's technically not yeah but
it's very much on the right you in your
heart it was yeah
but it's not a universally true
it's a personal Jordan with this lion
button not not a universal
exactly uh all right cool wow that was
amazing that was a good one good good
story I like it wafer on the grave I'll
use that man yeah the board boyfriend uh
hahaha
away from a grave waver on it is uh uh
uh wafer on uh uh my leg hair is Curly
oh man let's see a guy let's see what
this guy just killed the fox let's see
what the the sixth lead of triple
Frontier wants
what's up man Chris so I've been
watching the Pod recently to see if
anyone had a similar question to mine
but I'm just gonna have to make the
submission I saw myself I assume a lot
of people are have been or are going
through the same thing so
um I started dating this girl back in
May
um
the sweetest girl I've ever met in my
whole life
um couldn't think of a single con about
her we instantly hit it off it was
perfect we dated the entirety of Summer
hung out way too much probably
um and then
together but mostly her decided that we
didn't want to try the long distance
thing when she moved back to college for
her senior year um damn the thing I'm
really struggling with though is like we
kind of decided to pick it up
when she got back and it's kind of
leaving me in a weird spot where I'm
like trying to get over her but like
yeah still trying to hold on
um I'm doing the whole cliche breakup
things I just got back from the gym I'm
trying to like stay busy and everything
but I don't know if you guys had any
tips for me that'd be great love the Pod
guys thank you damn dude that's weird to
me kind of which part well he is not in
college and she is in college for last
year right that's what it sounds like so
it sounds like and so
they really like each other had a great
time
but they're doing the thing where they
are not going to be together because
she's away at college for the last year
I guess technically it's probably the
right thing to do to see if they were
good for each other but that just kind
of sucks man I just want to stay why
it's a good idea it's a good idea
because it's her last year of college
and she I'm assuming wants
you know the way people think is like
well it's my last year of college my
last year of like freedom and yeah
things not really mattering as much as
they do in true adulthood and I want to
be free so I can remember that for the
rest of my life as like my last Yeah
final triple Frontier of Freedom triple
Frontier but you know that's funny good
good job I get why people think like
that but life gets in the way of plans
like that and you if you met a guy that
you're really into yeah you shouldn't
really worry about that stuff I do get
it though here's the thing
the risk you run of sticking to plans
like that even when they stop making
sense because you've met someone like
you run the risk of
when you do like return to the
relationship it being different yeah it
was before the other thing though at the
same time staying together you run the
risk of that whatever is so good about
the relationship changing and by the
time you do get back it's already gone
so it's like
she should just drop out of college
you get you have plans and then the
plans
hula
you have played look I wanted to finish
that sentence but a yawn came through
okay you got to adapt I don't say the
same sentence I yawned regrouped talked
about the yawn entered the chat into a
different one this is the wisest thing
you've ever said you have to
grow or it dies and I say this all the
time grow or die you gotta grow you
gotta grow you had a plan you met a dude
you met a woman it changed now
all this being said could be her
secretly saying I don't want to be with
you anymore we don't know enough about
it yeah but I don't like reading into
stuff I know but I'm just saying you
should keep that in the back of your
head
because I don't think that
I I fully think that you should try and
I don't know how often you're talking to
her but I fully think you should try and
get over her because this is too much to
handle for a whole [__] year
and you run you run a great chance of
her coming back and [__] just not
working out that's that's probably
what's going to happen it could not you
know it might be 60 40 I don't know but
yeah but he's he's young she's looks
seems like she's maybe even younger like
what's the harm in trying to wait to see
if something sticks well there is no
harm because yeah no matter what happens
it's okay that's what I'm saying but I
think he should try to keep it going but
what does that mean though he she went
away to college and she they're doing
their own thing so he might as well
meet other people as well sure but that
you're saying it like forget about her
I'm saying oh I'm not saying like don't
talk to her at all that [__] yeah okay
you can keep in touch with her and stuff
but I think the second you're like we're
gonna try and you know this is my last
year of college you act single
sure yeah yeah yeah like don't be don't
be like halfway into meeting a new
person you meet a new person you go into
that date thinking this is going to be
probably awesome you know you hold out
the possible hold the possibility that
it might be even better than the thing
yes that is on hold for the time being
right yes and that's honestly great
advice and you're welcome
yeah that's tough though because like
the way the mind works it's not like
he's stuck in the middle and that
doesn't really help him get over it
stuck in the middle and you can't get
out of it well uh wow yeah it just kind
of sucks the only thing is that I would
say is that it's not that long it's like
less than a year it's a few months or
something yeah and you might see her
over Christmas break yeah you might see
her again you might get the Dome slopped
on you might you maybe go visit her
maybe she has a little break she comes
to see you who knows you might soak a
little bit that sucks man I hate that
kind of you might soak a little bit stop
you know well soak
uh oh damn whoa that was a whole episode
yeah all right
we appreciate you I'll be in Pittsburgh
I'll be in Cleveland I'll be in Virginia
I'll be in
um
a bunch of different places
uh Baltimore
uh uh and uh I can't wait honestly I
love doing this stand up it's really
really fun to do this uh where else am I
gonna be
it's your best hour thank you
Cleveland Detroit Orlando Fort Myers
Richmond
uh Philadelphia or reading oh yeah oh
yeah I just added Oxnard uh I'm gonna do
some new material in December that'll
sell out get the tickets and now also
Covina I'm gonna be in like two weeks or
something
it's like near La
uh at the Laugh Factory in Covina over
there get your tickets that'll sell out
too go see them in Pittsburgh on my
birthday oh yeah I know true
um so that's that and I got news uh the
specials coming out soon I got news
um I appreciate you guys and uh
patreon.com Lifeline luxury there's a
new episode up today uh and if you want
to go to watch lifeline.com send a link
we love the submissions you guys are
great you're sending good ones yeah or
call the hotline
you want one-on-one advice sessions with
Matt matthewlea.com yep and then our
Lifeline merch is
at Lifeline or sorry Lifeline merch.com
no app it's at and then also here we go
another part of this because you say the
ad symbol it [__] everything up
nowadays right it wouldn't have if you
just go merch.com and everything else
and uh thank you very much oh leave a
comment help the algae let's pump that
I'll go make sure you're subscribed to
uh super good Studio subscribe there we
go like
watch oh every episode
I'll see you again soon because you're
gonna watch another one right now bye
yeah at Lifeline luxury going over to do
that right now and we'll see you in he
double hockey sticks patreon.com is that
not what I said nope I [__] it up okay
every time you say it you [__] it up
it's crazy patreon.com absolutely what
do I say you either stutter like a [__]
or dick but you just say like luxury.com
like that's my luxury Lifeline
luxury.com like that's what it is and
it's not that's not that no it's
patreon.com
the episodes are amazing followers yeah
they're good we just banter and talk
[__] uh and they're great they're
great bye
hello hello
[Music]